would you recommend aspiring
screenwriters began writing novels
yes and no i mean certainly i think
there's benefits from
exploring different kinds of writing
most of my i would say sort of
leaps in terms of craft for any writing
usually
came from exploring other kinds of
writing and applying things i learned
so i mean i think i gave the example
earlier
about you know searching my screenplays
for l-y
to eliminate adverbs you know that came
from a book about writing novels
but i also think applying that kind of
screenplay structure
to my novels is what gives them that
cinematic quality that some of the
readers seem to key to
so i think it's certainly worth trying
you know i mean if you i think if you
enjoy it go for it if you don't enjoy it
i don't think you should
you know punish yourself and like force
yourself to write a novel if you're like
i really just want to write screenplays
if you don't enjoy the process
but i do think if you do enjoy it uh
it's certainly good to kind of
expand your creative muscles in other
areas i think only good things will come
from that
did you do a lot of short stories i did
i mean
when i first wanted to be when i first
took up an interest in writing i mean i
was very young i was a kid
and i really loved comic books and i
wanted to
be a comic book artist you know or
create comic books i don't think in my
head i had it split into writer and
artist i just wanted to make
comic books but i wasn't a very good
artist so
i started writing instead you know that
was what kind of led me to writing
and i really at that point in time i
kind of only thought of writing as
writing books
you know we're talking like six or eight
years old you know very young
and so i would start writing books of
course an eight-year-old is not going to
finish a book you know
i would start writing something and i
would lose interest in it immediately
and you know
that would be that and then i discovered
um
robert e howard who wrote the conan
stories
and uh the in that really kind of opened
my eyes that oh
like you know these are separate short
stories but they all feature the same
character and all set in the same world
so it kind of
builds this bigger thing you know and i
could wrap my head around
finishing a short story so i started
writing short stories then very
very much conan rip off stories same
kind of thing it was about a
viking fisherman with a trident you know
who like went around fighting monsters
and stuff
and but those were the first stories
that i sort of completed you know from
start to finish
where it was a whole thing so i think
that's that was pretty critical you know
to my development as a writer and that
really opened my eyes to
you know what it's like to like actually
finish something and to tell a complete
story
did you ever think about publishing a
book of short stories or no you always
loved the novel or novella form
um you know it's funny i haven't really
written a short story since i started
writing novels
i've thought about doing it but it now
seems really difficult i'm like wow how
could i tell a whole story in 5 000
words
you know i mean of course it can be done
but i should i really should i haven't
tried it but i should do that
and soon probably because that would
probably be good for my writing
is it harder to make a living as a
screenwriter or an author
well one of the reasons i kind of
gravitated to writing a book
at the time i was sort of discouraged
with my screenwriting and i figured well
you know writing a book seems way harder
so that means fewer people are probably
doing it you know i figure
i don't know if that's true like that
could totally be not true but that was
the
what seemed logical to me at the time
and that was kind of
why i kept coming back to trying to
write a book i mean there are a lot of
avenues
to uh making money through writing i
think it's hard to make a lot of money
no matter what you're doing you know
but in terms of like making some money
it's probably
i would say easier because a book is a
is a complete thing you know when you
finish a book that is
its ultimate destination it is a book
and someone can read it whereas a
screenplay
even the greatest screenplay in the
world is not complete you know until
someone makes a movie out of it it
doesn't really stand as its own
thing that you can monetize you know at
least not yet
so i think i there's probably more
opportunities to make money
as a as a author as a novelist but it's
also
in some ways uh harder work and takes
longer
and i think either way to be really
successful you need
you know a combination of a lot of work
and time and experience and luck
well the great thing too about novel
writing is you don't need
really much money to be able to do it
sure and
you know you can also document people's
thought process i think that goes also
for screenplays though i mean you don't
need money to write a screenplay but i
think
like the problem is once you've written
it you're
you are almost certainly dependent on
someone else monetizing it for you
you know you know unless you're planning
to produce it yourself
which is a whole nother you know level
of commitment and challenges
um you you can't monetize a screenplay
by yourself
you know there's really nothing you can
do that i'm aware of to just
start generating money from a screenplay
like you need to
have you need to interest other people
in it and then they need to option it
and then they need to get a movie made
and buy it from you and you turn it into
something else
whereas with the book once you've got
that book like there are avenues to
start monetizing it right away you can
you don't you can go the traditional
route and try to get an agent send it to
the major publishers but you can also
publish it on
uh something like wattpad or
self-publishing through amazon or you
know
all different avenues and do you think
that it's a it's a
do you think this is a fallacy that
people aren't reading as much you know
there's people well newer generations
they just want to watch videos on phones
whether they're
yeah i don't think that's true at all i
mean in fact i think
i think people are buying less books in
bookstores but actually ebook sales and
audio book sales
continue to grow year over year so
clearly people are reading i think
they're just shifting the formats that
they're doing it in
but i also think you know i think it's
important to
to point out that if you know even in
terms of books if you want to make money
from writing books you do you i would
very strongly caution people again to
stay away from that lottery thinking
you're not going to write one book
and become like a millionaire you know
it's like you have to formulate a
business plan in essence it's a business
you know and either a business you're
running yourself or a business that
you're you know
working with publishers on one way or
the other but it's still a business and
so you need to look at
you know how much are they going if
you're going to a publisher they're only
going to pay you a certain amount up
front and then they're going to pay you
in installments and if the book doesn't
sell those installments aren't going to
come and
how many books do you want to write a
year and how many books are they willing
to publish a year
if you're going to do it yourself and
self-publish like
how are you going to draw eyeballs to
that first book you know how
how are you going to keep your output
consistent so that the readers don't
drop off while they're waiting for that
next book i mean
i i think that there's you know there's
the creative challenges of writing a
book but the moment you want to start
making money off of it i do think it's
important to kind of look at it
a different way you know put on a
different hat and make a
plan like it's not just going to no
one's just going to magically hand you a
stack of money no matter what route
you go you know so you need to have a
plan of how you're going to
monetize this and turn it into a
business and even if you do
get that one huge hit especially
previously in other years where it seems
like
people could make way more money maybe i
don't know maybe the deals were
structured differently
but it'll be what have you done for me
lately you won't be able to just rest on
that one project yeah i mean the amount
of writers the authors that
really make you know massive incomes off
their writing is really small
i mean it's i'm not saying you can't
make a living you absolutely can
but like you know that stephen king
level money is really rare
i mean even if you look at traditionally
published authors most of them are not
making anywhere near that you know
they're making
you know kind of normal salaries really
you know like
you could make the same amount of money
probably doing something else
so you have to really you know love this
and love the process and think it
through and plan you know and put
save money because you can have i've had
good years and bad years with what i'm
doing and not every year is equal
you know so if you have a slow year it's
good if you have some other streams of
income
you can rely on or you know savings that
you can rely on so
i just i think when you but more i guess
more above all that what i want to get
at is that when you do
invest in that lottery thinking i think
that's when you get discouraged you know
when it doesn't turn up
that you know and you're sure this is
going to be the thing and it doesn't
and it doesn't catapult you into like
you know being a multi-millionaire
i think it's really easy to kind of look
at that as a failure and give up but
it's a much longer process you know i
think you just need to
be prepared for a longer haul and look
at it that way you know don't look at it
like
i'm going to write this book and make a
billion dollars okay i'm going to write
this book you know maybe it'll make some
money and then what am i going to do
after that how am i going to build that
up into something else
i love that terminology and i think
we've been really spoiled with that
especially whether we watch
mtv cribs or you know from going back to
you know gen x or whatever
just we're taught that
it's sort of like one and done and it's
so easy and if you can just get to that
level
and so much of it is but even those
people even stephen king if you read his
book
you know the book that made him
successful was like his fourth or fifth
novel i believe you know
he published the others under a
pseudonym and he'd been writing for
years and he you know had sold short
stories to magazines and he'd been at it
since he was like 16 years old you know
i think we the media likes these instant
success stories because they're
glamorous and exciting and fun but
even those stories if you really look
there's usually a lot more work
you know behind the scenes than what
you're seeing and it it takes
years to really achieve that kind of
success i kind of think of it like
and that's why like i said before like i
think i i'm
upset that i let my you know
self-confidence wane
not because i think it i would have been
amazingly successful but i just it just
kept me from doing the things i should
have been doing all along you know
because it's a process and it takes time
it's like going to the gym
you're not going to go into the gym one
day and walk out looking like sylvester
stallone like that's
everyone gets that you know that's not
realistic but for some reason i think
when we think of creative
endeavors we think that oh we're going
to do this one and it's going to be you
know star wars or something
that makes you billions of dollars and i
just
i'm sure maybe that's happened for like
a tiny percentage of people but that's
essentially betting on a lottery ticket
so
and i think it's much easier to kind of
look at it realistically
and say okay i'm going to write this
book and it you know
maybe it's not going to change my life
but i can realistically see it making a
little bit of money
it'll it'll pay back the editing costs
and the cover costs and maybe give me a
little
bit more and then i can do the next one
and i'll have more readers
and you know it's a career that you can
build up over a few years
and if you look at it that way you can
plan intelligently rather than
dump that first book out and then get
upset when it's not like a bestseller
right away
yeah and did in on writing stephen king
talked about he was teaching and he
worked in a laundromat and
i think if i'm remembering correctly
different odd jobs
yeah absolutely and and um
even when he's quote unquote made it
then he had a new set of problems
yeah that he also talks about which
that's its whole
other ball of wax but being alone in
that room and and
occupying your mind different things
that you
spoke of as well even like what people
when people talk about how they wish
they could just
you know get paid to write like i said
like sometimes that's
sometimes that's great but sometimes it
may not be what you really thought it
was you know you might not enjoy it as
much as you think you would so
sure everything yeah and everything has
so many hours put into it that we've
never seen
yeah yeah a lot of people like the idea
of things
yeah yeah i like that million dollar
idea that's good
how does a writer figure out whether
they should write screenplays or novels
i mean i do both so
and i enjoy both like i don't think i
would want to give up one or the other
but i think that once you've i think you
need to do both to know right how can
you know if you haven't tried
and if you've tried one and hated it
then you know you know but uh
i think if you like both there's no
reason why you can't do both i don't
think there's
i think they have similarities and
differences and like i said i think as
you get better at one
you'll find things that you can apply to
the other and vice versa and your
writing
will improve what about to the writer
that says
i really want to be a writer whether
it's screenplays or novels i just don't
have the time
i think that for a small
percentage of the population that could
be true but for the vast majority of
people i think that's just an excuse
i mean we all have the same amount of
time and
i wrote most of my first novel while i
was fully employed
i just you know i just had to get up
early and i would write for
an hour before i went to work you know
um again i think
i think the people that think that it's
kind of that lottery thinking again
because they're like oh this is gonna
take six months you know or
i can't i can't just do it right away
but who cares if it takes six months
so what you know i mean it probably
won't if you really think about it i
mean if you wrote
a thousand words a day which i think
most people could probably do
in an hour maybe two hours
so you know 70 that's 70 days that's
what two months you know
two and a half months you could have a
book so i don't think
i think it's certainly a daunting thing
and most people's first books take way
longer than they think
they will because like you know you just
haven't kind of worked that discipline
yet you're just not used to
sitting down every day and doing it but
once you do that
you i think it's easier than people
realize
and it you you just have to find the
time i mean it's if it's important to
you
uh you know watch a half hour less of tv
every day
stop surfing the news yeah yeah that's
probably super helpful these days
and it's not even a you know i'm not
saying i don't think you have to make a
drastic sacrifice it's not like cut out
all tv i mean of course i still watched
plenty of tv and i still do but
you know just a little bit less like
just find
find find the time i mean i tried that
actually it was very freeing this was
back
uh when reality tv was just starting so
it was actually very freeing
to just completely have no where i lived
that if you didn't have cable you
couldn't watch anything and it was just
very freeing i did i remember when i
switched to uh streaming
like uh i cut cable because i
you know i was uh watching some
god-awful reality show i came here what
it was
i was like why am i watching this like i
i'm not even interested in this remote
right but it's just on
so that day i canceled cable and i just
only did streaming because i was like at
least with streaming i am choosing to
watch
whatever i watch maybe it's garbage but
i picked it you know whereas with cable
it's just like whatever was on next like
you just sit there you know kind of
zoning out
it's the same now with scrolling just
like why am i scrolling through this
instagram feed
okay stop you know and and it really
takes a lot of it's too easy to be
mindless but
now i mean look if you're a mom with two
kids and you're working
like i get it i'm sure it's super hard
to find sure i'm sure there's people
that are having trouble
but even if you can set aside 15 minutes
you know i mean even if you can write
200 words a day
it'll take you a while but you'll get a
book you know
you